I'm here to see Ilona Reese
we are now watching you know you're
dealing with a very explosive patient oh
you've been a lawyer two years where it
kind of all to be a lawyer only two
years I mean what are you slow she's
died but danger to herself or others
this is my lawyer she knows exactly what
her medication is doing to her and she's
furious about it this is where I write
down what it does to me nobody knows
more about what that medicine does to me
than I do
yeah tell me I'm not right
we win you would be representing 150,000
people now listen to me this case this
could take years I just want you to know
you're up against excuse me James Adams
counsel for st. Mary's and I believe you
already know dr. Booker you seen the
care package that the hospital sent over
trying to bury us in paperwork honey you
can't keep pushing yourself like this
I don't know it all get one yes they can
sometimes have side effects but these
medications are the only effective
treatment was over before we started the
hospital asked the Supreme Court to
review the case it's crazy
we you can't let this ruin Christmas you
gotta have faith
till that
how good does that do
he went my case to make other people's
lives better
you know like your own life what do you
think it's fine it's not fine it looks
like a balloon
[Applause]
what do you want to help because I'm
here is your friends
they were forcing medications on earth
this is about the right to refuse
five stops
you're a brave woman
yeah she's a nice person and she's a
good lawyer yeah even if she did lose
today that was a joke
Colette
[Applause]
you
you